Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr eight.
It's the Monday morning podcasts for Monday,
October 22nd,
2012 and I know we get thinking,
Bill,
why does it sound like you're inside of a fucking tin cans?
Well,
I'll tell you why
I'm in fucking Australia.
I just plugged my goddamn mixer into the fucking adapter and it just shorted it
out.
All right?
It's my fault.
What was I thinking?
Running such a gigantic podcasts such as the Monday morning podcast with a $99
mixer.
And I did say gigantic podcasts.
This is a big podcast.
It's fucking big to me every week on iTunes.
Where?
Number 37.
You like that?
I'm the only podcast too.
Who doesn't lie?
Okay.
All these cuts out there.
Be fucking one of them.
Dude.
I got like a million downloads.
I'm number one.
I go fuck yourself.
Yet when you get number one in your ass,
um,
I'm here to tell you that I am number 18 and I'm proud of it.
So anyways,
I don't have any headphones.
I don't even microphone.
I'm recording this thing through garage band and this is how it's going to
sound.
All right?
And if you don't want to listen to it just hit stop cause it's not going to get
any fucking better than this.
All right?
You like how I'm kind of yelling at you because my mixed,
cause I bought a $99 mixer to run the 47th top 47th podcasts on the fucking
iTunes.
Um,
all right,
let's get right down to it.
Lance Armstrong officially fucking stripped of all of his God damn titles and
Nike has the fucking balls,
the fucking balls to walk away from Lance.
You didn't walk away from Tiger Woods,
you know,
after all the bull shit he was doing.
So I guess if Lynch just fucked around on his wife,
you know,
you still would've had a swish above is fucking left tit.
You wouldn't have had a problem with it a night.
When the fuck do you get off?
Haben any sort of moral stance about cheating or not cheating,
you know,
if you taken a look at your company lately,
you think Lance doesn't have the right to fucking go around handing out those
live strong bracelets because you think he cheated.
Well what about you guys?
Huh?
What about you?
Nike just do it.
What does that mean?
Is that what you say to the children?
Who,
so your sneakers together in El Salvador
is Sona Jack do it?
Um,
yeah,
we had a fucked as Nike.
I mean you know what it is.
I loved that.
That's when Nike,
Nike drops them in.
It gets to look like they don't tolerate cheating.
It's all about money.
With those cons,
they don't give a flying fuck whether he cheated,
whether he didn't cheat.
All right.
When it looked in fat,
like this guy had been busted,
they walk away like Whoa,
that's not what we're about.
If anybody out there can explain to me what fucking Nike is about other than
money standing on the heads of eight year olds,
um,
you know,
if you can come up with something else,
send me an email.
I,
cause I for one would love to hear it.
All right.
I hope this isn't really a help.
This recording isn't as bad as it looks.
It looks like I'm fucking blowing out your eardrums.
I'm trying here people,
little handicap TM down on deck,
having a nice time down and uh,
um,
uh,
Jesus Christ a fucking made it over here.
Everybody.
14 hour flight,
you know,
with no drugs.
I was thinking of,
you know,
watching a couple of movies and then taking some drugs and I actually,
I worked it out.
I got on the plane,
immediately fell asleep and uh,
I slept for maybe,
I dunno,
about six hours and then I just watched movies.
Well,
what'd you watch bill?
While I watched caddy shack,
then I watched on the waterfront,
then I watch national Lampoon's vacation,
Chevy chase still fucking hilarious.
And then I watched a,
a bgs documentary,
which got really fucking boring really quickly.
And uh,
then all of a sudden we landed and that was it.
So there you go.
I know.
I watched something else in there.
There was something else ran that I started to watch.
Is there watching a couple of documentaries and I know what you think of bill
[inaudible].
Who the fuck would ever watch your goddamn documentary on the bgs?
Well,
you know,
I had 14 hours to kill.
All right.
You're judgmental cunt.
And not to mention the BGS are from Australia.
Figured maybe I'd see something in there that I could bring to my live shows.
MMM.
Oh whatever.
So we land,
we land here at like six 30 in the fucking morning.
We basically,
we left at 10 o'clock at night,
Monday night,
flew for 14 hours.
And by the time we got here it was six 30 Wednesday morning,
you lose a day.
You know,
it was an 18 hour fucking difference between La and here.
I don't know if this is interesting,
I don't even know if you can hear me.
You know,
I don't fucking know.
MMM.
Florida.
Yeah.
So then it was weird cause then we landed here and uh,
then I had to stay up until fucking about nine 30 at night to try and get on the
clock.
And,
uh,
I dunno if it took a couple of days.
I kept bitching about B and jet lag to the point.
I think dom I rare was going to slap me in the,
I think I had like 14 conversations with him about how I just,
I couldn't go to sleep,
you know,
and the lovely Nia,
she's more of a hippie free spirit than I am.
Right?
She just took sleeping pills the first night.
It was fine.
And I'm all sitting head,
you know,
trying to be fucking Johnny Natural Bitchin about what the fuck they do to your
liver,
like another guy of some sort of a doctor,
you know.
So finally the third day here,
I actually took some sleeping pills and I slept through the night and I felt
great,
you know,
so there's one for the druggies,
hey me and you taking sleep and kill me in and it actually works.
Um,
so anyways,
I performed at the Sydney Opera House downstairs in the basement.
It was a 400 seater and,
um,
did three nights.
Every show was packed and,
uh,
just great crowds and,
and it was a total,
this district was a total success.
And I'm definitely coming back here because not only did the people come out,
uh,
it's just a great country.
I don't have one fucking bad thing to say about Australia other than the fact
that Sydney is expensive.
Jesus Christ as his fucking place,
expensive.
And I led the New York City and that place is expensive.
Okay?
It's not like I'm some sort of redheaded farm boy over here.
You're not talking to fucking huck Finn.
You know,
I'm not sitting here barefoot with a goddamn fishing pole over my shoulder.
All right?
Oh,
I got one bad thing,
one bad fucking thing.
All right.
Last night we were coming back from watching these bats fly out of the park.
They call them flying foxes.
I guess they're furry.
It was night.
It was nighttime and they're all,
you know,
hundreds of fucking bats flying out.
It was awesome.
And,
um,
so we're hungry and uh,
we were going to go to the burger king out here,
but they don't call it burger king.
They call it hungry jacks because evidently there was some other guy out here
already had a place called Burger King and he sued the Burger King Corporation
and somehow we won.
So for some reason,
Burger King settled on the name Hungry Jacks.
I don't know why,
but they have the exact same logo in the menu.
So we go into hungry jacks and is which stand there.
All of a sudden this guy and a tank top comes in with these two blonde girls and
one of them is just loud as fucking hell.
Okay,
I'm standing there and then she goes,
I was like,
that's a crazy fucking laugh.
Like really close to my ear.
Like,
and I'm thinking,
did she just do that to with me or can she not handle her alcohol?
And then I guess,
you know,
on their cell phones you can get,
they had some coupon for a free burger or something.
So she goes,
look,
I got a coupon for a free burger.
And she,
and then as she's,
she fucking reached past my face and shook her cell phone in front of my fucking
face.
And I can't believe I didn't slap her fucking phone down into the fryer layer.
It's been bugging me.
And uh,
when she went to order,
she,
she said to the guy behind the counter,
she goes,
just meat and cheese,
just meat and cheese like three times in a fucking row.
Just being a total obnoxious cunt.
And
I tried to not let her get to me,
but I just kept replaying that fucking shaking the phone in my face.
She did it.
She shook it right in my fucking face.
I didn't do anything.
I was so like surprise.
And then there's,
then there's that weird like it's a woman,
so you gotta do the math.
Like what do I do?
Like I,
I'm telling you the amount of times today,
the fucking violent thoughts,
I kept trying to think of anything I could have said.
Anything I could've done,
the only solution I could have thought of other than what I did,
which was nothing,
was,
would they were all violent solutions.
I thought about,
well,
what if I just took my shake and dumped it over our head and the fantasy
immediately went to me taking a burger and like mushing or interface slash like
punching her with the palm of my hand through the bread.
Would you be considered assault?
I thought about dragging her out by her fucking hair
and then throwing her cell phone like fucking Randy Johnson in his heyday and
having it smash right above her head.
And then just sitting,
watching her cry as I went back in and got my food and some,
and somehow in all of these I never get,
never got arrested.
But,
uh,
that was the only one bad thing.
Like this girl was like so overdue for a fucking ass kicking.
Um,
I really wished I,
I just knew like,
you know,
those chicks who fight in the UFC,
I just wish I knew one that was in the vicinity and could have just had her come
in and dress like really like,
you know,
all girly girly and just kind of act sheepish and just let that girl come up and
do the obnoxious thing.
That's shit that she was doing.
Oh my God.
I W I W oh,
I would've paid 500 bucks
to talk to have a woman,
not just,
if there was a service,
I would have paid $500 to fucking watch a woman go in and just knock this bitch
out because she just,
it Wa it would have made her a better person.
Okay.
It really would have,
like today I'm fucking sitting here,
you know,
doing touristy shit.
I walked from,
uh,
what it Bondai beach to cookie beach or whatever.
Okay.
Fucking incredible.
They've got all these,
uh,
the word of sand sculpture.
I don't know what the fuck they call them,
sculptures and stuff.
I gotta be honest with you.
I could give a flying fuck about him.
You know,
sculptors,
you know what they do?
They take like a garden hose and some PCP pipe or whatever the fuck it is.
You know,
they take junk from the kitchen and they,
and they make like a fucking,
I dunno what a rocket ship out of it.
I just,
I've never been into it.
It's clever.
But you've seen one,
you've seen them all.
Nia on the other hand,
absolutely fucking loves them.
So she stopped and at every God didn't one of them.
It's windy as hell.
I got salt spray in my face,
but I'm like,
I'm liking it though.
I'm liking the,
uh,
the elements.
But um,
but half of the walk I just kept thinking of grabbing that girl last night by
our hair and throwing her off the cliff.
You know,
she lives but she breaks her fucking hip and she deserves it,
you know?
And when she looks at me like why?
I just say,
cause you're a cunt.
And that's the end of the fantasy.
Is that bad?
Other than that,
I had a great fucking time out here and I'll tell you all about it right after.
Uh,
I do a couple little ads here.
What do we got here?
Uh,
lending tree.
Um,
if you're hitting,
if you have a mortgage on your home and you haven't looked at refinancing a,
you need to act now rates are at 3.125% APR,
which is at an all time low.
If you go to try and lending tree.com complete an easy form that takes less than
five minutes,
you will have up to four lenders sending you options to review and compare.
Try lendingtree.com now and if you went to the code Berbee you are are,
you will see a free mortgage mortgage guide.
All right,
www.lendingtree.comorgototrylendingtree.com.
Excuse me.
Um,
anyways,
so back to my trip here,
back to my trip here.
Uh,
what did I do?
I went to the zoo.
I went to the zoo and earlier that morning,
one of the zookeepers,
unfortunately a lovely woman got crushed against the wall by a,
a baby elephant or an owl adolescent one.
You know when everybody was feeling bad for her and we all hope that she gets
better,
but you know it's one of those fucking dales.
They,
they don't want to be there.
That was the overwhelming vibe that I got will,
especially the fucking chimpanzees and the gorillas.
Okay?
You know what I would love?
What I would absolutely love is to go to church Sunday and listen to some guys
speaking that fucking creationism Mumbo fucking jumbo and in the background,
just have a bunch of apes sitting in cages staring at people in the fucking
crowd of the church because I'm going to tell you something right now.
I don't give a fuck how much you're in de Jesus.
How much you in dumb Mohammed,
whatever the fuck you're into.
There's no way to look up fucking monkey in the eye and not know exactly where
the hell we came from.
There's just no way.
Somewhere along the line,
they broke left and we broke,
right?
But I'm telling you,
if you go up the family tree,
oh fucking long enough.
Look at my dumb face.
You're telling me I'm not half orangutan.
There's no fucking way,
there's no god damn way.
Those motherfuckers,
they,
they uh,
uh,
just a cunt hair away from being human and they're,
they're aware that they're being watched.
They don't want to be in there,
you know,
it was really bad.
They had this giant area where they were playing and then they had this one air
where they could kind of walk into like this little cave,
you know,
and they walk into the cave trying to get a little fucking peace and quiet,
just don't want to be stared at anymore.
And there's a big window so we can see him in there.
And I see this one goes in there and I of course run up like the tourist that I
am in,
this mother fucker gets in there.
So that's going wow.
Fucking slap in the walls and jumping around.
And I said to Neil like,
that one does not,
is,
that's the one right there that's going to rip your face off because you know,
that dude's the man and he's caged up.
All right,
you got to fucking Alpha male.
They're like,
he's not a bitch and he doesn't want to be in there.
And him just slapping the wall and whatever the fuck he just yelled.
And Chimpanzee,
if you translated it to English,
would basically be like,
you mother fuckers are so lucky that glass is there.
Because if you weren't,
I rip all your faces off.
I'd rip a couple feet off and a bunch of ball bags.
So consider yourself lucky.
So anyway,
so I leave Nia stays and all of a sudden the monkey starts fucking acting up and
somebody's standing there going and he's saying he's going to charge the glass.
And that's exactly what the thing did.
And everybody jumped back and uh,
and then another monkey ran in there and all the humans will like,
oh,
they're going to fight.
And when the other monkey ran in there after the other,
the Alpha chimp flipped out.
When he ran in there,
the two of them just hugged each other and then they sat down,
started grooming another.
It just made me feel bad.
You know,
I don't mind rep,
you know,
you're going to stick something in a cage.
Make it a reptile.
I was fucking idiots.
They don't know what's going on.
You know,
I gotta do is throw a dead mouse set.
I'm every couple of hours and they're fine reptiles or the mouth breathing
morons are the fucking animal kingdom.
They just,
they,
they're clueless.
You know,
it's like they'll like those people that sit out in the bleachers,
you know,
those jackasses.
That was a Rep.
Thomas.
Um,
speaking of which,
um,
speaking of sports,
I've tried to keep up on the sports.
I've been actually,
you know,
something,
I've been over here so long,
I'm starting to like crickets,
which I've got to tell you something right now.
You know,
as much as they bitch about,
uh,
helped me moving this computer.
Is it making a bunch of noises?
Um,
as much as people bitch about how difficult hockey is to watch on TV.
You ain't seen shit until you try to watch a game of cricket when there's nobody
there to explain what the fuck is going on.
Um,
for you yanks out there who never seen the Goddamn game and it looks like
baseball played with a fraternity paddle.
Do you know that that field is 360 degrees.
There's no foul balls.
You filed tip that motherfucker and it goes over the wall behind you.
It's six runs.
That's what you get for a home run.
Six runs,
it gets to the wall.
That's four runs.
There's two guys with paddles.
When you hit the ball,
they both tried,
they run at each other,
go to each other's basis.
And if they can do it before those clients get the ball in,
that's a run or two or something like that.
And they play,
they have like fucking 50 outs.
Okay.
And they got a quicker game,
20 something or other that only takes a day.
But in a cricket match takes five fucking days.
Good Lord.
He thought baseball was born,
but I got to admit,
after a while I kind of started to get into it,
got into it a little bit.
But um,
I dunno,
what else did I do on it?
So we went to the zoo.
That was a great time.
Um,
other than the fact you just looking into the eyes of animals that don't want to
fucking be there.
But uh,
oh by the way,
the two major animals here,
Koalas and Kangaroos,
not a fan of either one.
Now that I've seen him up close for wall is like they just got that look on
their face.
It's depressing.
You know,
I've been,
I was joking on stage,
my shows down here.
I was saying the reason why I didn't like for Wallace,
because when I looked at into a Koala bears face,
it reminded me of every time I quit in life.
You know,
they just have that fucking,
you know,
what's the point man?
You know,
just sitting there high off that fucking eucalyptus shit they eat.
They're like potheads some reason they remind me at Tom Bosley,
you know,
Mr,
see Mr. Cunningham on happy days,
like if Mr. Cunningham was a fucking animal,
he,
he would be a Koala bear.
Mr. Cunningham would be not Tom Bosley.
Okay.
Cause obviously he didn't sit around and do nothing.
The guy made it as a fucking character actor.
All right.
And kangaroos are fucking rats.
They're rodents.
They got this little fucking head.
That's really weird.
They just,
they just creepy.
All right.
And,
and my version of a kangaroo where those funny ones that they drawing cartoons,
they're not funny at all.
They fucking like six feet,
six feet one,
they're like as big as Eli Manning and they can,
uh,
you know,
basically rip your guts out with their front feet if they choose and uh,
where they can jump twice as far as Michael Jordan.
So that's,
that's pretty scary.
See,
I learned shit when I was over here.
You know,
you guys just think I'm going around drinking fucking beers,
which I did
really.
Bill,
can you recommend a good Aussie bear?
Yes,
I can.
A little creatures Pale Ale.
It's fucking delicious.
Um,
all right,
I'm trying to space out,
do a little better job here with the,
uh,
the advertising this week.
I'll just read them real quick,
one of the time here and then get back to the podcast,
a amazon.com.
Thanks again for helping to support the show by going to my Amazon banner on www
dot [inaudible] dot com podcast page.
Before you buy something online,
um,
this one extra step.
It helps support the cost of producing the podcast as well as help the,
uh,
the wounded warrior project where I give a percentage of my advertising revenue
too.
So thanks again for going there.
There you go.
Big Bang.
Boom.
You like that quick commercials this week back to the podcast.
Oh,
so this morning,
my patriots,
the New England Patriots were playing the green cunts,
the New York jets.
They were playing them,
I thought at four in the morning.
They were actually the four o'clock game,
which was seven in the morning here.
So I got up at four in the morning and I actually watched him,
my computer.
Um,
I watched 'em.
What did I watch?
I watch the giants versus the Redskins,
thanks to my opening act.
My support is,
they call it out here.
Nick Cody cooked me up.
Yeah,
with his NFL username and password.
And I was able to watch most of that game before crapped out on me.
And then I had to go to Ed to go to a casino,
which was five minutes down the fucking road.
But there's so much traffic here in Sydney and they only have like two lanes on
each side.
It took forever to get over.
Um,
and then watched the Patriots first,
the jets,
Jesus,
Jesus.
And you know what I saw during that game,
I saw two teams that are not going to win the Superbowl this year.
MMM.
I actually think Rex Ryan is doing a hell of a fucking job considering all the
injuries that they have and,
and Bella check is doing a hell of a job considering we have absolutely no
secondary whatsoever.
They definitely played better this week.
But um,
you know,
we won the game,
but I can't,
I can't even talk shit.
It's like we,
we,
we blew the game and then they,
and then the jets were like,
oh no,
you don't.
Oh No,
Well,
we're going to blow the game.
How dare you try to make us win this game?
And then the patriots like,
well,
wait a minute,
we don't want to win this game.
You win the game is you?
Yeah.
Will fumble the ball during the kickoff.
The jets go.
Okay,
well we'll,
we'll,
we'll see your fumble and we'll drop an easy pass and just kick a field goal.
MMM.
I Dunno if we just had somebody,
I was,
I,
I gotta be honest with you.
I was really surprised that we won that game because I really,
you know,
Defense Wins Games and I felt that the jets had a better defense or have a
better defense that we do,
even though Reavis is out.
Um,
Cromarty still a great player and uh,
we just don't,
we just don't have that guy in the fucking secondary.
But,
uh,
but he was hilarious.
I can't remember I even fucking told this story yet,
cause I had to start this podcast three fucking times cause it's so weird to be
doing this without hearing myself headphones and all that type of shit.
But anyways,
um,
I went over to the star casino.
You know what's hilarious is I'm 50,
50,
whether I already told the story,
I hope I didn't.
Um,
I went over there and they were,
there was nobody there.
I walked into this sports book.
There was nobody there.
There was this Asian dude playing some weird game in the corner and,
uh,
it had the whole place to myself.
It was actually kind of cool.
And,
uh,
I dunno,
is it weird that it,
like I got over there by nine in the [inaudible]
morning,
I'd watched the first app on the computer before crapped out on me at nine in
the morning and went over there and I just started drinking by myself.
I had three beers.
I told myself I was only going to have to like,
then once we fucked up and fumbled,
I was like,
yeah,
fuck it.
I'll have it.
I'm going to fucking drink my sorrows away cause we're gonna lose this game.
And somehow we want,
you know,
anybody go to the game out there.
How many fucking,
okay.
Fairweather fans left after we fumbled the fucking kickoff trying to beat the
traffic,
those Douche bags.
So,
uh,
I dunno,
I'm psyched that we won,
but in the long run,
is it,
is it really going to help the Patriots?
You know what it is,
you know,
what's really hurting the Patriots?
How good Tom Brady is in belt bill Belicheck and our offense is because we went
so many fucking games that we shouldn't.
And uh,
then we don't get a high draft pick and we really need to,
we need to get somebody cause anybody coming out of college that's just not
going to be a lights out.
Cornerback has,
God knows we could fucking use one.
Oh,
and by the way,
I absolutely fucking hate those old school,
New England patriot and uniforms.
And I know there's a lot of people that like it,
but all I see those and I get sick to my stomach.
I see those uniforms and all I think of is Dan Marino throwing for 500 yards.
You know,
I think of the bears patriots super Superbowl,
I think a Tony [inaudible]
um,
Irving fryer before he got his shit together.
Um,
I roughing the passer against the fucking Oakland Raiders in 1976.
That's all I think of.
I just think of losing or coming close to winning and then fucking losing.
That's all I think of about whenever I see those,
those uniforms.
Although you know,
if I see a tee shirt that has the old pat Patriot helmet on it,
I'm a sucker and I'll buy it.
But I,
I hate seeing us.
I just hate seeing us wear those uniforms.
It's,
it's just not a good time.
I imagine people will,
uh,
Tampa Bay Buccaneers fans probably feel the same way when you have the cream
sickle uniforms.
Doesn't that just remind you of Oh,
and 14,
I guess you had Doug Williams,
you had that one year and like 79 where you got all the way to the,
uh,
the NFC championship game where I believe the Los Angeles Rams beat you nine to
nothing.
Norming Cromwells kicked three field goals.
Isn't that what happened?
And then they played the Pittsburgh Steelers,
the roid it up Pittsburgh Steelers.
By the way.
That's for that comment on Twitter.
That gave me shit about the patriots cheating.
It's always funny to hear a Steeler fan talk about cheating.
You really should go back and see why you had the steel curtain.
It should've said the steroid curtain.
Jesus Christ.
Even Terry Bradshaw admitted that he was using steroids.
Um,
but whatever,
whatever they got synergetics now they're giving up the fucking old people.
Um,
so anyways,
how farmer to this fucking,
okay.
Horribly recorded podcasts.
My half hour.
Look at that.
Moving right along.
Let's uh,
let's turn on the fucking light here.
Oh,
by the way,
I didn't make it up to the Great Barrier Reef.
I didn't make it up there.
It was just going to be too much of a thrash and uh,
I actually found out how to do it the right way.
You know,
granted,
I heard that they,
they're going to allow the public to go to the Great Barrier Reef for much
longer.
And if they don't,
what,
what are you going to do?
You know what I mean?
I think the barrier reef is more important than,
uh,
this freckled face con actually seeing it.
Uh,
let's,
let's get to a question for this week is an advice.
One brother in law bill.
So my brother in law is a fucking pussy.
He is the poster boy for Napoleon Complex.
He smacks his wife around Jesus Christ,
doesn't keep groceries in the fridge for his kids.
Talk Shit.
About how he'll eat my lunch to people once he has a couple of whiskeys and
cokes in him.
The guy's a real piece of shit.
Despite all of this.
I've never judged the motherfucker,
never made a big thing out of his drunk shit.
Talking on me.
Always gave him the benefit of the doubt.
Well,
did you judge him for fucking slap in your sister around,
right?
If he's your brother in law,
then his wife has to be a system
or is it on your,
your,
could it be on your wife's side?
I don't know how that shit works.
I never understood that.
This is my third cousin,
Eh.
It doesn't mean shit to me.
I don't know what that means.
Do you have three cousins?
He's three times removed.
Um,
anyways,
a couple of weeks ago it all came to a head and an aunt ended up having to kick
his fucking ass after he showed up to my two year old daughter's birthday party
drunk and caused a scene in front of my family.
I'll be the first to tell you that I don't like confrontation.
I don't walk around like I'm some bad ass tough guy.
This stuff has been brewing for a while though and that night I had no choice
but to grant his wish and beat the shit out of him.
Well,
good for you.
I got to say it felt pretty fucking good too.
I imagine it did.
It feels good for me to find out that you did it.
Um,
anyway,
so fast forward a little bit.
My wife's sister is now sending text messages about him wanting a rematch,
blah,
blah.
Also,
it's your wife's sister that he's slapping around.
Oh,
this guy wants a rematch.
The guy writes lol.
We live in close proximity.
So it is not unusual to see these slugs at the same grocery store or liquor
store,
gas station,
et Cetera.
So when the time comes and I do see this stupid little fuck,
how do I play it?
I have nothing to prove.
I don't like to fight.
I'm 31 years old and have a family,
but I'm,
but I'm certain this cunt will put me in a position when I do see him.
If you were me,
how would you go about handling this situation when it does arise,
which I'm sure it will sooner or later.
Thanks bill.
MMM.
What would I do a,
I call him up.
I called the guy up the lovely Nia.
Everybody don't,
yeah.
Um,
I would call the guy up
and uh,
I tried it that way.
Call him up while he's sober and you're sober.
You do it over the phone so it doesn't escalate to a physical thing.
And I would just say,
listen,
I heard that you're saying that you want a rematch and all that type of stuff.
All right?
I don't want to fight you.
That's not what I want to do.
But if you put me in a position,
I will defend myself and the outcome is going to be the same.
All right?
Stop being a fucking pussy.
Learn how to hold your alcohol.
All right?
But I'm gonna tell you right now,
I am not looking for a fight,
but if you come at me,
I am going to pound your short little ass into the fucking ground in front of
your wife and kids.
All right.
That's what I'm going to do.
And by the way,
stop slapping around your wife.
I don't know.
That's probably bad advice.
Maybe say something better than that,
but,
um,
do it over the phone.
Is there a nice way to say that?
Just say,
listen man,
I don't want to fight you.
All right.
I heard that you want a rematch.
It's unfortunate that things got physical.
That's the route you go because you won the fight.
So there's no real,
you don't have to gloat.
He knows what happened.
All right?
You know,
you got out of hand,
you know,
maybe you to go to AA or something.
You know,
you seem to be a really chippy when you have a couple of drinks.
Um,
and then when he starts yelling all this stuff,
just say,
listen,
I didn't call up to argue with you.
I'm just telling you I don't want to fight you again.
All right?
Please don't put me in a position to have to fight you again.
Just leave it there.
Ah,
you know what,
you guys,
you know what?
It's inevitable.
You guys are going to fight.
All right,
so just drop that guy.
Give him a fucking straight right.
Just fucking rightness.
Fucking chops.
Why don't you go over there?
Just go over there and fight him again.
Kick his ass and it's Rome in the bushes and just laugh as you watched that
little fucker tap to crawl out of them.
You know,
you know what I'm worried about,
sir?
Is it,
you're going to end up getting sued.
You know that's something that the little [inaudible] this guy in the,
he's actually the fucking,
I dunno,
he slaps his wife around.
Does it keep groceries in the fridge?
He can't hold his alcohol.
The guy that wrote you?
No,
no,
no.
The guy that wrote me this is his brother in law.
His brother in law on his son.
His sister.
No,
I don't know.
I think it's his wife's sister.
I mean,
I,
I don't get it.
I don't get what's going on here.
I don't know what we're talking about.
I mean,
cause if he slapped around your sister,
you should do with James Caan did in the,
in the godfather and beat the fuck out of him with every,
you know,
trashcan on the block.
Okay.
I Dunno,
I don't,
it seems real.
I Dunno.
For some reason his question wasn't about how do I get him to stop hitting his
wife.
Yeah.
That's Kinda the main issue,
isn't it?
I Dunno.
I don't think that that's,
I don't think in his world it is.
These might be a,
that you see that show Gypsy blood when we were over here.
Yeah.
Like those guys like fucking there.
They have cockfights they kicked the family dog around and they have their kids
sit there.
Pete have half hour fights with each other taking punches to the head and this
and that going go,
you got it.
You got to convince this woman to leave this asshole.
That's the thing.
Uh,
that's a real,
why wouldn't you do that?
He's slapping her around Lima.
He tried to tell her that some leave him.
Well,
why wouldn't she leave?
You know what I mean?
What do you mean?
There's a,
there's a million reasons why people stay in abusive relationships.
It's not so black and white and like,
oh,
you're getting beat up leave.
It's sometimes more complicated than that.
Well,
yeah,
I know,
but you can't just go over there and be like,
hey,
you know what you should believe like,
like she doesn't know the guys slapping her around.
I'm just like,
you ain't got to have some like,
hey,
you should leave and I have an apartment for you.
Well,
yeah,
sure.
Cool.
Like that's like,
because other than that you're like,
that's like walking up to somebody broke going,
you should win the lottery now it's,
it isn't.
All right.
Well I'm stupid.
Listen,
don't get mad at me.
Okay.
I have to make it,
I have to keep it funny.
I understand.
I understand that guy shouldn't be hitting with the girl and he should try and
help them out.
I mean,
that goes without saying.
What,
what,
what?
What are they supposed to do?
Well,
I don't know.
I mean,
yeah,
that's a tough one.
But I mean,
if the wife wasn't around the husband it might,
it might help a little.
It might help a lot.
It sounds like.
I Dunno.
It's hard to get involved in people's,
they should stuff that little fucker in a trashcan.
Put duct tape over the lid,
poke some holes in this or the cut can still breathe and then just move his wife
out to a safe place.
There you go.
And then roll the guy down the hill.
All right.
It's a dilemma for Junia.
If you could be invisible for a day,
what would you do?
Invisible for a day.
What would you do?
MMM
hmm.
I Dunno.
I would probably sit in on 'em
people's therapy sessions.
Really?
Yeah,
it would cause I'm really interested in that kind of stuff.
Anyway,
psychology and know you can just be a therapist.
I know.
I want it to be a therapist for a long time.
Yeah.
I always said like if I wasn't doing what I'm doing now,
I'd maybe like go back to school for it.
But yeah,
I was going to be an invisible for a day.
That's what you would do.
I think I would.
Is that weird?
It's weird to me because I'm a p obviously you're way nicer person than I am.
Oh,
why?
What would you do?
Oh my God.
This a zillion things.
Everything from look up women's dresses.
What are you fucking two years old to a,
you can just go online and just see a woman,
not the sagittal canal.
Okay,
so you don't need to like lay down.
We are no sidewalks.
Yeah.
Like
I need to do,
that's the dumbest.
What a waste of our visibility.
That's a fucking waste.
Or you're terrible at this.
Or I would,
uh,
I go to the CIA building and I just start reading files.
That sounds more like you while I looked up dresses of agents.
Yeah.
You got to do something perverted.
Look,
I'm just being honest.
There's no way I could handle the power of being invisible.
You don't have to be invisible in order to see women's like private parts that
doesn't require,
yeah,
build it.
You can just do it on the Internet and yeah,
but that's not the same.
That's like,
oh,
I can also watch that fucking Oliver Stone's JFK movie.
That's not like walking into the CIA building and reading all this stuff before
they black it out,
you know?
Okay.
But that makes more sense to do invisible rather than look up somebody's skirt,
whatever.
It's your fucking visibility.
Stop taking my visibility away.
Lame.
What's the next one mean?
It's,
you know,
something near my CIA thing was better than you.
[inaudible] that's like,
that's like a job.
You could just go do that.
That's like,
what would you do if you were invisible?
Um,
I go to a construction house,
construction site and watch him build a house.
He just be a construction worker.
No.
Do it that.
It's more about like being nosy about people's business.
That's why I want to be invisible.
Well,
what you're doing is the female version of me looking up address.
I'm looking into their mind.
Well,
look,
if,
if so I'm likely cheaper than you.
If guys did,
then you,
if guys genitalia looked a little better,
you'd be laying down on the sidewalk to looking at ball bags.
Yeah.
Gross.
I know.
No one wants to look at a ball bag.
Exactly.
So that's why you're not a better person,
but yet.
But everyone wants to see ah hoo.
Ah,
AH,
alright.
Dilemma.
All right.
You were just given a yacht.
What would you name it?
It's not really a dilemma about
Ah,
why is that a dilemma?
Fuck,
I was just given a million dollar boat.
What would you name it?
Hmm.
I Dunno.
I would,
I would name it tender headed.
Oh God.
Yeah.
It's my name of my company.
It's my whole branding identity is tender headed.
Why wouldn't I not supposed to be something kind of like funny is what are you
going to name and go fuck yourself.
And I don't know off the grid.
Uh,
key low a board.
No,
I told you if I ever had a boat I would definitely does.
No Way.
I would not be moving drugs.
I wouldn't be able to handle that power.
Just taking a fucking water taxi.
Just being out there.
It's like I'm out on the water.
It's nobody out here,
you know?
Hmm.
I could just,
I would,
I would fucking,
I would have every once in a while,
not all the time.
Every once a while I would have a brick,
a weed or a kilo of coke and I would just be out there by myself just out there
naked
jerking off on the seas and just having a good time.
I wouldn't handle,
I could,
I,
you know,
this is a reason why I'm where I'm at in society.
God knows better.
Every once in a while he fucks up and then he lets a crazy person through.
Um,
all right.
How far are we into this thing?
I'm really hoping this isn't going to sound fucking horrific.
You pause it and listen to it for a second.
I did.
That sounds,
it sounds like I'm in a fucking tin cans the best I can.
So there's no like levels here that I can fuck with and I don't know.
Um,
can you give me,
can you put that thing all the way to the right?
Does that do anything?
I Dunno what that does that,
that maybe turns it up.
Yeah.
I have no idea how any,
uh,
how have you enjoyed being in Australia?
Oh,
I've loved it.
It's been amazing.
And shout out to all the cool people that came to your show.
Absolutely.
And were nice enough to say hi to me.
That all good.
A lot of people were like,
they were like the lovely Nia.
Yeah,
that was really nice.
So shout out to all you guys had said hello to me.
That was nice and made me feel really special and welcome.
And now the city is amazing.
Having a great time.
Definitely want to come back.
That was probably the nicest 11 seconds.
Everyone was very sincere.
It's true.
I've felt very welcome by.
Bye.
Frys it's true.
I really liked it.
People in Australia are so nice.
You know what?
I think it's time to talk about sweet,
sweetest day.
All Mr [inaudible] love the podcast.
We beat the duper duper on or you know what I oh wait,
I gotta I gotta I gotta read.
I gotta reach a commercial here real quick.
Uh,
what the hell is this one?
stamps.com.
Everybody,
you know the drill,
you want to go to the post office for the rest of your life.
God,
that's your choice.
You know what the rest of us are doing?
We're going to stamps.com and we're bringing the post office into our dwellings
are tent city,
our homes,
our houses,
our tps.
Uh,
would it be great if you could have a,
if you could print legal postage at home anytime of the day while invisible
looking up skirt.
Um,
look,
you know what you get,
you get the scale,
you get a,
you get a no risk trial.
You're used my last name bur bur for the special offer plus $110 bonus offer
includes the digital scale and up to $55 free posted.
She getting $55 for free.
They give you a little scale,
you know,
so if you've got something you want to put in a box and you want to figure out
the post as they can do that,
it's just like the post office,
except it's in your house.
It's awesome.
I use it whenever I send out my DVDs.
And a,
I highly recommend it.
Go to stance,
stock calm.
Before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of the homepage and type in [inaudible],
B u r,
r,
and you'll get your $55 free bonus postage stamps.
Stop comment or bird.
All right.
Onto the sweetest day,
Mr. Burn,
love the podcast.
Bubba.
Okay,
onto my question.
My wife keeps busting my balls to participate in what I call a bullshit holiday.
Yeah,
it's called sweet,
sweetest day.
I've never even heard of this says certain areas of the Midwest celebrates
something called sweetest day on the third Saturday in October.
It's just another excuse for cards,
flowers,
candy,
et Cetera.
I am originally from New Orleans,
New Orleans and didn't move to the Midwest till 2009 until then,
I was unaware of this.
I was unaware of this holiday even existed.
This is the first I'm hearing of it to sir.
Never heard of this at all.
Exactly.
It says,
I am also in the military,
so we live outside of Ohio.
The first six years of our marriage,
this holiday was never even mentioned once.
During that time.
So every year since moving to Cincinnati,
I have refused to partake like clockwork.
Every year I catch flack cause my wife's friends slash family brag about the
gifts they received.
Am I being a Dick for not participating in this?
Should I stand my ground or given to celebrating something with only regional
importance?
Any help would be appreciated.
Go Fuck yourself and happy for me to stay.
And do they not celebrate Valentine's Day there.
This is basically what it is.
This is an extra Valentine's Day.
This is like when the NFL wanted to add more games in the players union was
like,
fuck that.
We're already getting enough concussions.
This is the Valentine's Day version of that.
So there's one in February and then there's one in October.
Oh,
get her something nice so she doesn't have to feel shitty in front of all those
people.
What's the big deal?
Get some flowers.
This is what the deal is.
There's some Perth.
You take her out to dinner?
No,
wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
What?
What the fuck is she going to get him?
Okay,
isn't it?
It's not a mutual thing.
Don't try to back your out of this.
You weren't even trying,
you weren't even fucking even remotely thinking about the guy in this.
Wow.
I wasn't until you just mentioned it,
but yeah.
You weren't get her this getter that.
Yeah.
What about him?
You already have Valentine's date.
We already have to buy you shit.
You guys don't buy us a fucking thing on that.
What have you ever gotten me for Valentine's Day?
It's not x.
That's a show.
I love that too.
Like how you guys consider sex.
Like that's a chore for you.
Like it doesn't feel good.
I wish there was a holiday where I just like,
let you blow me after you took me out to dinner.
Isn't that something that men are trying to get going?
That's something I was trying to get going.
No stake in a blow job day.
You know what and I'm telling you if,
if,
if you lady is a champion,
she'll actually enjoy doing that.
Making you a stake in fucking blowing you.
Maybe that's the compromise.
Let's do something for each other on the sweetest day.
How about that?
We'll both,
you know.
Yeah.
You know what I want you to do.
You want,
you want,
I don't want you to do for me on,
on sweetest day me.
Yeah.
What?
I want you to forget that it exists and my gift to you is that I'll do the exact
same thing.
Give me a fucking break.
You want to go out?
If you want to go out one night,
just say you want to go out,
don't do it.
But the ship,
I don't have to go out and go buy a bunch of candies and all that crap.
Who came up with this sweetest day thing.
The fucking people will make the candy.
Yeah,
but how can we use his Christ?
Do you have to be invisible looking through files to figure that out?
But how she came up with the Suzuki Samurai's tips over easily.
The people who make the jeep.
But how can we haven't heard of it though.
How come it?
Yeah,
it's,
it's a regional thing.
Like why is it because people in Cincinnati are dumb and they don't realize that
they're getting fucked.
Don't,
I don't know why.
I have no idea.
I,
I dunno.
I Dunno why it goes on there.
Yeah.
I mean it's definitely kind of ridiculous to have to participate in just because
everybody else is kind of ridiculous.
It's completely fucking ridiculous.
They can compromise my both do it.
Let's do like a special day together and it's,
it's a together thing as opposed to let me go out by yourself.
So just so you can show off to you,
you know something about all of this shit that's just shit that you'd be going
on in your relationship anyways.
You shouldn't have to fucking go,
you know that,
you know,
hallmark said stand up and salute and then you stand up like a fucking Zombie,
fuck you homark fuck yourself.
Fuck all your days.
Fuck all of that.
What do we do every year for Valentine's Day?
We go out the day before Valentine's Day.
Day after day after day.
But you don't even know.
Yeah.
Not on Valentine's Day to avoid the crowds because Sam's go out day in the
inflated prices and we have a great time.
Oh,
it's phenomenal.
Yeah.
February 15th is one of the greatest nights.
That's love.
Or go out
to dinner.
Nobody's out.
You just do what you do it that way.
So what,
so what should he say to his wife about this?
And he'd just be like,
I'm not ready to just be in this bullshit.
I don't want her to have to go through what I go through is what does she have
to do?
He,
she's go,
hey swaty and just when she looks at the grand,
it's grabbed his dick.
I got y'all today.
Right here for some sugar.
Right on my deck.
Right.
There you go.
There's your fucking ballpark.
No,
it's stupid.
Um,
she probably knows it's stupid too,
but you know,
everybody else is like,
oh,
you didn't get you.
Who is this Brad Rad?
No,
we don't need names.
Oh,
you don't name names?
It's Chad.
Chad.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah,
it's my fault for showing it to God.
Look,
um,
yeah,
the third Saturday in October.
Yeah.
That's weird.
Well,
I,
it,
it's,
it's yet another one way holiday.
This is what I would say that would be like,
I would just be like,
look this,
there's already a Valentine's Day.
Christmas is right around the corner.
You know what I mean?
And it's like,
when was the last time he made me a steak and blew me because it's fucking steak
in a blow job that we got.
We really have to come up with a day.
Maybe it should be the third Saturday of October.
October is Halloween.
Sweden.
Let's,
let's,
let's figure this out.
All right.
Okay.
January is new years.
February and Valentines Day and Abe Lincoln's birthday or George Washington or
something like that.
It's black history month.
Black history month.
Okay,
so that's out.
Um,
March.
March is Saint Patrick's Day.
We got,
we get,
it's got to be a month left.
That feels like something that would fall in line with Saint Patrick's day.
It's taken a blow dry day.
It sounds like you just can't get a drunken Irish food would come up here.
That then it gets to Frat boy and then you get that,
then it becomes date rape.
Then it becomes rapey.
April is Easter
in April fool's day and Hitler's birthday,
so that's out for 20 minutes.
May Mother's Day.
Memorial Day.
God Damn.
June is father's day.
Father's Day.
June.
That's weird.
Huh?
Like for father's Day,
like if your husband's a father,
give him a snake and a blow job.
A blow job to bits.
Right.
She want to stay,
I don't know.
July that fourth the 4th of July.
Yeah,
that works.
No,
no.
It feels like more of a fall holiday.
Honestly.
The staking a blowjob.
What about August is nothing in August.
Yeah,
that's,
yeah,
this is good.
They go to the end of the summer,
August or September.
Corn is in season.
It's very phallic looking.
There you go.
Come up with a day.
The 17th okay.
August 17 that's right.
Have a blowjob like lucky seven and one blowjob.
You heard it here first folks,
August 17 second a blow job there.
You know what?
There's a lot of women out there that are actually going to enjoy doing that.
Put it in the calendar so when it comes up next year you make a big
announcement.
I got to get this thing going.
I have to trending on Twitter to get it going.
I got to get blow job out of there.
It's got to be a Vegan and Bj,
well what you do is the steak thing.
You'd be supporting a beef farmers,
right?
So you add a John Cougar Mellencamp sort of farm aid thing too.
What does that mean then the blow job ever get Willie Nelson and all those guys
to do it and then the a blow job.
That's a tough one.
Yeah,
there you go.
There,
there should be a podcast listeners.
This is your homework for the week.
How can I sell this thing?
Um,
without people saying that it's completely fucking sexist.
All right,
that's it.
we're winding down here on the podcast,
so let me make sure I've gotten everything that I need to get to.
What are we up to here?
54 minutes of tin can listening.
Um,
all right.
Amazon lending tree.
I already did that.
Game Fly game flying every go game,
flight.com everybody.
Hey,
would you like 8,000 video games at your fingertips with a 15 free 15 day free
trial?
Go to game,
fly.com/burr or through the game flight banner on my website podcast page.
The free trial is a $23 value and you will get two deaths of whatever game for
whatever video game system you want.
There's no strings attached.
If you don't like the service,
just returning the games and cancel your subscription,
you can't lose gain flights.
The best service out there to play the new games again for free trial 15 day
trial exclusive to listeners of the Monday morning podcast,
go to gamefly.com/burr and uh,
required to do this one twice.
Once again,
lending tree,
everybody interest rates are the lowest they've ever been all time low.
3.125 you're looking to refinance your mortgage.
Go to try lending tree.com and now if you're under the code Berbee you are are,
you will receive a free mortgage guide.
All right,
back to the uh,
to the podcast here.
All right,
that has alliteration.
But how are you going to get the red states?
Are you going to get the Bible beaters?
You know what,
it needs to be one of those underground holidays,
you know?
Yes.
Go out the main stream.
I like it.
Just like the podcasts.
Podcasts is where we're kind of underground.
When he blasted the hallmark,
they're obviously an ethical,
had anything to do with fuck call mark hallmarks right there with Nike.
Just do it.
Keep sowing you piece of shit.
Give us the money.
Yeah.
It's so ridiculous.
Um,
and they,
all I talk about is the shame of Lance Armstrong.
What about the shame of having people have to sweep raw sewage out of their
fucking houses during the rainy season because you're not paying them enough
money that they got to have a door on their fucking concrete dwelling.
I don't,
what are you going to vote anyways?
Anyways,
um,
we got anything left.
Oh,
he's the last thing for this week.
Learning Spanish.
Uh,
what's up bill?
I heard you bitching about Rosetta stone on your latest podcast.
I wasn't bitching about it.
I was frustrated that,
uh,
I don't have the time to commit to it.
You were bitching.
I was a bitching.
You always bash.
Yeah,
but I wasn't bitching about Rosetta stone of pitching that I couldn't get the
fucking,
I had lost the disk.
I like Rosetta stone.
Okay.
All right.
Then he said,
dude,
that's old technology.
It's like you're still trying to make phone calls with one of those backpack
windup army phones we used in Vietnam.
Jesus Christ is that old.
Uh,
yeah.
It's like he goes,
just give this a try.
It's a free website.
I'll fuck you in your advertising and trying to get in here.
Okay.
He says this,
this,
this other place.
The format.
Okay.
The format they have for learning a language,
in my opinion,
is far superior to resent a stone.
I'm,
I'ms ,
I'm guessing this person actually make some money off this.
He Goes,
plus there's no fucking software and it's free tracks your progress and it
allows you to communicate with other users if you're having trouble.
Very helpful.
Just trying to help out a fellow ginger.
All right.
Ginger has got to stick together.
I,
I am a redhead.
I'm from the states were called redheads.
All these people in the states using that expression.
Ginger is fucking hilarious to me with the fucking,
what was Austin Powers steam out of nowhere.
Was that ginger?
How is,
I know ginger is red,
but what is it about ginger that is rent?
Like where did they came up with spice,
isn't it the spice?
Yeah,
baby.
You look at a ginger using a ginger root before it's now red.
No,
you have I put it in.
Oh yeah.
Yeah,
I am.
Yeah.
What are you talking about?
It's not right at all.
Oh,
I don't know how it came about from fucking dry.
Ginger is,
well,
I don't think so.
I have no idea.
Anyway.
Um,
so you know what's funny too is how people keep sending me things saying that
redheads are going to be extinct by the year 2080.
It's like,
it's so alive.
I mean,
what,
how is it gonna Affect My,
I won't be extinct.
I'll be dead
from fucking old age.
Hopefully.
I don't understand how redheads are supposed to be extinct.
Like a whole,
I'd like,
there'll be no more people in the world who have red hair ever.
Like what,
what,
based on what
dos or somebody said something on the Internet and all these fucking morons who
aren't qualified to pass it on.
Yeah.
I'm going to go ahead and,
and say that that's probably an urban myth.
You know,
it's funny,
as I was describing what they were doing,
I realized that I describe what I do on stage every night.
Yeah.
By the way.
But that's the fun.
Great.
When my shows I was,
when I was out here,
shows were amazing.
I fucking had a great God damn time I died.
I can't wait to come back here next time I come back here.
It's over,
man.
I'm doing a whole fucking tour.
Next time I'm going to do Perth,
Melbourne.
Fucking was it Biz,
Bain and fucking Brisbane,
Brisbane,
Adelaide and uh,
and fucking,
where are we symphony with the Farsi call?
Sydney.
I'm going to do that.
Whatever.
I'm tired.
All right.
That's the podcasts and the sweet guys.
I'm sorry.
I shorted out my mix.
Um,
I hope you enjoyed it.
next week I'll be back back to,
well,
I'll have to buy new fucking mixer and I'll,
I'll,
I don't know what I'm [inaudible]
well,
you're going to get rid of your ham radio.
Wait,
died.
I mean,
I don't know what to tell you fucking died.
All right,
well that's the podcast and once again,
seriously no bullshit.
Thank you to everybody who came,
uh,
to my shows here in Sydney.
I know a lot of people traveled a long,
long ways.
Yeah.
To come to my shows.
I had an awesome time.
Um,
and I am definitely,
without a fucking doubt coming back because Australia is the shit.
All right.
That's it.
Go fuck yourselves.
Have a good week.
I'll talk to you later and thanks for [inaudible]
coming on with me now.
All right,
you're welcome.
Okay.
Bye.